.
EVEN PRESIDENT MACRON WAS
SCOLDING BIDEN FOR HIS IDIOTIC
COMMENTS AND BEHAVIOR.
RETIRED LIEUTENANT COLONEL
OLIVER NORTH IS HERE WITH US.
HE WARNS IT'S THE WORST CRISIS
SINCE THE CUBAN MISSILE CRISIS
AND THAT WE ARE NEARING NUCLEAR
ARMAGEDDON, HIS RESPONSE IS TO
GO TO THE BEACH ON VACATION
INSTEAD OF HEADING TO THE
SITUATION ROOM.
WHAT I A PROBLEM WITH THAT
COLONEL?
>> WE ALL OUGHT TO HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH IT GREAT THIS
PRESIDENT IS SEVERELY
COMPROMISED BOTH MENTALLY AND
PERHAPS EVEN ETHICALLY BECAUSE
OF WHAT HIS SON MAY OR MAY NOT
OF DONE WITH THE COMMUNIST
CHINESE.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT ADD UP TO
A COMPROMISE COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
IT'S STUNNING TO ME THAT
STRATEGIC TARGET LIKE THAT
BRIDGE COULD BE SO POORLY
DEFENDED OR PROTECTED BY THE
RUSSIANS.
PUTIN CALLED THE BRIDGE ATTACK A
TERRORIST EVENT.
THIS MORNING, HE'S GOT BALLISTIC
MISSILES AIMED AT CIVILIANS.
POLLUTANT WAS EITHER IN HER JUST
COME FROM AN EMERGENCY MEETING
WITH HIS VERSION OF THE NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL.
SOME IN U.S. INTELLIGENCE
SERVICES BELIEVE BOUDIN MIGHT'VE
CALLED HIS ADVISORS TO GET THERE
APPROVAL TO USE THE BRIDGE
ATTACK AS A PRETEXT FOR
ATTACKING KEITH.
BIDEN'S RESPONSE TO CONDEMN THE
ATTACK OF THE STRONGEST POSSIBLE
TERMS, HE SAID HE TALKED TO
SAUL ALINSKY AND PROMISE THAT WE
ARE WITH THEM NO MATTER HOW LONG
IT TAKES NO MATTER WHATEVER YOU
NEED.
WHAT ZELENSKYY NEEDS AND IS NOT
GETTING FROM THE AMERICANS, THEY
NEED THE ABILITY TO KNOCK DOWN
RUSSIAN MISSILES AND ROCKETS.
BUT IT'S REDUCED BECAUSE OF
EVERYTHING HE'S BEEN DOING
AGAINST CIVILIANS, BOUDIN, SINCE
FEBRUARY.
THE MISSILE DEFENSE SYSTEMS,
U.S. DEPLOYED PATRIOT BATTERIES
WITH U.S. TROOPS TO SAUDI ARABIA
WHEN THEIR CITIES AND REFINERS
WERE UNDER ATTACK.
NOT LIKELY CAN HAPPEN HERE.
NO U.S. BOOTS ON THE GROUND AND
TRAINING ON PATRIOT'S FORMER
COMPLICATED THAN THE OTHER
TRAINING THAT IS WORKED SO WELL
IN THE EARLY PHASES OF THIS
WORK.
THE ISRAELI IRON DOME WOULD BE
PERFECT HERE BUT THE ISRAELI AND
RUSSIANS ARE COOPERATING TO DEAL
WITH HEZBOLLAH.
YOU WANT LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
OKAY.
SO HE CLEARLY IS NOT DOING AS
WELL AS HE THOUGHT HE WOULD DO.
HE THOUGHT IT WOULD BE A
CAKEWALK.
HE'S BEEN EMBARRASSED ON THE
WORLD STAGE.
HE'S TARGETING CIVILIANS, WHICH,
BY THE WAY, HE BEEN DOING FROM
EARLY ON.
HE HAS BECOME ISOLATED AND
PARANOID.
PEOPLE AROUND HIM SEEMED TO BE
DISAPPEARING ON A DAILY BASIS.
IF HE IS WILLING TO TARGET
CIVILIANS THE WAY HE IS IN SUCH
A BRUTAL FASHION, IS IT LIKELY
TO ASSUME THAT HE WOULD BE
CAPABLE OF USING A TACTICAL
NUCLEAR WEAPON AS HE SAYS HE
MIGHT?
>> SEAN, I DON'T BELIEVE YOU
CAN.
FIRST OF ALL, THE 1991, WE HAD A
LOT OF OUR SCIENTISTS HELPING
THE U.N. REDISTRIBUTE THE
WEAPONS AND GET THEM OUT OF THE
PLACE IS PLACES LIKE UKRAINE.
SECOND, HE'S GOT A VERY SERIOUS
PROBLEM OF KEEPING IN HIS OWN
TENT THE PEOPLE WHOSE SONS ARE
NOW FIGHTING THE WAR.
THE BOTTOM LINE THIS IS THAT I
DON'T THINK POLLUTANT CAN BE
SURE OF BEING ABLE TO CONVINCE
SOMEBODY TO PUSH THE BUTTON THE
SYSTEMS ARE VERY MUCH LIKE OURS
BECAUSE OF THE SPIES OF THE BEEN
WORKING FOR US SINCE
WORLD WAR II.
I THINK HE KNOWS HE CAN'T
CONVINCE PEOPLE TO PUSH THE
BUTTON, TURN THE KEY, OR ENTER
THE CODES, BECAUSE HE'S HAD SO
MANY DEFECTORS FROM WITHIN HIS
OWN GOVERNMENT.
PUTIN IS IN TROUBLE.
HE MAY NOT SURVIVE THIS
EXPERIENCE.
>> Hannity: I SAID FROM THE
BEGINNING, I HOPE THERE'S SOME
RUSSIAN HIGH-RANKING PEOPLE
AROUND THEM WHO MIGHT KNOW WHAT
THE RIGHT THING TO DO ISN'T TAKE
CARE O